my name is Quintin Scranton I'm the
executive chef of crazy John's
restaurant in Lafayette Louisiana today
we're cooking crawfish croquettes
otherwise known as crawfish boudin balls
39 years ago prejean started as a
crawfish boiler room I would say pray
John's is legendary in Lafayette I
wanted to make a crawfish etouffee
boudin ball because it's my
grandmother's recipe so you're gonna
cook your vegetables first and then once
you add your tails you add the stock so
that they don't get rubbery and hard you
know I didn't think my grandmother
taught me much until I got older I
learned her little nuances and I learned
her attitude towards cooking her general
way that she feels about why she cooks I
wanted to make a crawfish boudin ball
out of her recipe to kind of make sure
that she sticks around
boudin traditionally from the French
style of cuisine but really it was made
in Louisiana rice is just as important
as protein and a poutine what I like to
do with these croquettes specifically is
add a little bit of Gouda cheese it
gives you a smoky flavor a little bit of
creaminess boon I got started because
people did not have enough meat they had
to use what they had which was starch or
rice they had to cut their sausage with
something a little bit more easily
accessible first it goes in the flour
then it goes into the egg wash and it
goes comes with a crack one batter then
it goes back into the egg wash then he
goes into the crack one batter for the
last time the cracklin batter is
something that gives you a little more
kick a little more Louisiana flavor then
we fry a pretty much made out of blue
there all right ate it since I was a
baby I can remember whenever I was six
years old at my uncle's restaurant he
just sat in the back and watched them
fry seafood and he's a prude and
sandwiches all day a lot of major
cultures they always congregate around
food crawfish etouffee is one of those
things for Cajun culture that people get
excited about the crawfish gives it
something that's more than a garnish
it's kind of something that it almost
sounded alone because it's such a pretty
presentation by itself when it comes to
what you see it's just as important to
what you taste eat with your eyes first
imagine salty spicy and crunchy on the
outside and then creamy me and filling
on the inside it's a delicious
bite-sized piece of heaven
[Music]
[Applause]